That service, that commitment,
honor, pride.
That's why I became
a police officer.
My name is Michael Dominique.
I serve in the United States
Marine Corps.
I left as a sergeant.
I served in Iraq
and South America.
I'm here as a police officer
at Yale University.
One of the hardest things
coming back from Iraq
was acclimating back
into everyday society.
People don't know exactly
what you’ve gone through,
especially if you've
gone to war.
They don't know that camaraderie
that you've had
when you've served alongside
other veterans.
The majority of the
service members
that I looked up to growing up,
they're no longer here.
Before a lot of them passed,
I was able to show
that sign of respect
by becoming a marine,
joining the service.
So, that’s what
Veterans Day means to me.